il y a un an les premiers patients du
coc u19 étaient admises dans nos
hôpitaux et il fallait les soigner sauf
que trouver des traitements contre
locaux vides ça a été assez compliqué et
ça l'est encore alors quels traitements
ont vraiment fait leurs preuves
jusqu'ici
et qu'est ce qui a changé dans nos
hôpitaux pour mieux prendre en charge
les patients au début de cette vidéo on
ne peut pas s'empêcher de parler des
deux traitements qui ont fait énormément
parler d'eux depuis le début de la
pandémie hydroxy chloroquine du docteur
house et le remdh et s'ils virent du
laboratoire américain gilead
il s'est avéré qu après de nombreuses
études ces deux traitements ne servait
pas à grand-chose commençons par la
chloroquine l'efficacité de cette
molécule mise en avant par didier rahout
suscite toujours un vif débat pourtant
depuis cet été de nombreuses études
sérieuses arrivent aux mêmes résultats
l'hydro xi chloroquine ne fait pas
baisser la mortalité ni la sévérité des
symptômes et ce même quand elle est
associée à l'antibiotique azithromycine
et puis le rêve des civils n'a pas non
plus fait preuve de son efficacité cet
antiviral qui était utilisé à la base on
trémolat n'a donné aucun résultat
probant
le ms l'a rejetée dès le mois de
novembre et discovery l'essai clinique
européen qui teste l'efficacité des
médicaments contre locaux vides 19
là également et cartes mais même sans
ces traitements on a trouvé comment
mieux prendre en charge les patients qui
arrivent à l'hôpital pour le comprendre
on a demandé à charles cazanave
infectiologue au chu de bordeaux alors
il ya un an il faut dire que l'on ne
partait de rien
on avait vraiment pas de pistes
thérapeutiques sérieuse donc on faisait
ce qu'on appelle du traitement
symptomatique en traiter la fièvre ont
donné de l'oxygène méthode assez simple
mais la révolution qui a eu lieu c'est
plus par le biais des traitements
anti-inflammatoires donc l'inflammation
qui se produit généralement septième
huitième jour de la maladie ou la grâce
à la cortisone un vieux médicament
pouponner tient à fortes doses que l'on
m'a donnée assez précocement dans les
stades de la pathologie appartement on a
besoin d'oxygène a révolutionné la prise
en charge du co vide et c'est vraiment
ça je pense le gros progrès sur la
thérapeutique plus de la cortisone
la deuxième évolution c'est ce qu'on
appelle look to you know they rap en a
dans les service de maladies
infectieuses utiliser les système
d'oxygénation à haut débit et qui
permettent d'apporter des hauts niveaux
d'oxygène de façon assez confortable
pour les patients et d'éviter justement
le transfert en animation pour
l'incubation qui reste quelque chose que
l'on essaie de faire le plus rarement
possible grâce à ses différentes
méthodes
plusieurs indicateurs ont baissé dans
les hôpitaux que ce soit le taux
d'admission dans les réanimations où le
taux de mortalité donc on meurt - duc au
vide et on a moins besoin d'être admis
en réanimation est plus à un autre
aspect sur lequel a progressé de
l'hôpital c'est celui de la rééducation
post maladie puisque souvent les
patients après nécessité d prise en
charge particulière et là aussi aller
nos confrères de rééducation les
éducateurs on a des services spécialisé
dans la rééducation coville qui peuvent
assurer une suite de prises en charge
dans ce que les patients ne peuvent pas
directement en paix chez eux et mettre
en place une rééducation très adapté
donc pendant ce temps la course pour
trouver de nouveaux traitements continus
vous avez peut-être déjà entendu parler
de celui de tester par l'institut
pasteur 2011 vous avez fait une vidéo
pour vous expliquer pourquoi ce
traitement ne serait pas disponible
avant longtemps il est aussi la
colchicine qui serait efficace selon
l'institut de cardiologie de montréal
selon les chercheurs cette molécule a
réduit de 21% le risque de décès ou
d'hospitalisation chez les patients
atteints de kobe 19 comparativement au
placebo sauf qu'ils n'ont pas encore
publié
données de leurs études et que cet anti
inflammatoire peut aussi être dangereux
si les utiliser lors d'un contrôle
médical très strict la prudence est donc
de mise
et puis il ya aussi les anticorps de
synthèse développé par le groupe
pharmaceutique américain eli lilly tu
sais ce traitement expérimental qui a
été utilisé pour soigner donald trump
début octobre 2020 en europe l'allemagne
a proposé un accès à cette thérapie sous
certaines conditions et si les premiers
résultats sont encourageants
plusieurs fins sont apparus les
capacités de production sont limitées et
se produit coûte très cher environ 6000
euros pour une enfin il ya les anticorps
de patients ayant déjà eu le quotidian
protocole national qu'à une participante
dans dix corps de plasma de personnes
qui ont guéri du coded qui ont un
placement riche en anticorps
donc ça c'est des choses que l'on peut
utiliser on était à diminuer le portage
tirade
sauf que les experts s'accordent à dire
qu'il faudrait davantage d'essais
cliniques pour comparer cette méthode au
soir tan dung au final on comprend qu'il
faudra encore attendre pour trouver un
traitement dont l'efficacité contre le
commis 19 éprouver et documenté sur le
long terme par exemple si on fait une
analogie avec le dégage traiter une
maladie nouvelle
les premiers antirétroviraux réellement
actifs
on a lu des années à les avoir on essaie
d antiviraux qui existe et après tout ce
qui est du développement de nouvelles
molécules et ça prend du temps
et en effet on est contraints par le
temps dans cette pandémie
donc peut-être qu'on aura quelque chose
de spécifique mais pas de suite de suite
ça c'est une moindre remarque
[Musique]